I felt like thank you I felt like I just
followed up the most incredible musical
group like we started with Sonny Rollins
anybody know who's sending Rollins is
okay and then I got John Coltrane next
so and then I looked at the time and I
realized what I heard about Miles Davis
a once you know they were playing them
and thinking plated in the village and
trained Coltrane who was noted for
taking long courses very very long
courses that miles was sitting on the
side he kept blowing in his mouthpiece
and went you know 20 minutes went by
most Coltrane was still doing his thing
so finally John came down officer said
sorry mouth baby I'm sorry says buses
just take your horn out your mouth well
I don't I'll kind of do that today so
make me take my morning on my mouth okay
we have a first oh I uh I think I love
about Barbara she really does believe we
should take the tools of our scholarship
to save their species the ultimate value
to me
that causes all religions and all
cultures it's a survival of our species
and that is in debt in danger in it's in
danger because of the kinds of issues
that Barbara talked about well I'm
basically a scientist of teaching and
learning so what can I do to help
contribute to the solution for the
problem the problem is poverty it's
gut-wrenching poverty our only way to
begin to nibble at poverty is not just
equity in education that's a necessary
it is not sufficient we have to have a
super effective educator
and we've talked about this for decades
and for 27 years we've developed the
science of teaching I want to tell you a
little bit about it it's just one of the
model of us about 10 schools in the USA
and England and Ireland and somebody
tell you about I'm proud to show some
data about how we did bridge the gap but
didn't in some ways finalists
okay so what effective education means
this is a slide I added to the one I did
this in India blast they have the same
problem but they just have four billion
people priority is a source for health
incarceration unemployment etc it's
responsible for the one in 100 people in
the US that are in prison said necessary
if not sufficient step took self to
accelerate the learning of all of
children and bridge the gap as well as
make the bridge higher
we can't just bridge the gap you know
when I go to India and I go into private
schools in India and there were 40 kids
in the class for the moment point
oh well above grade levels and they're
just now beginning to get the kind of
technology we could deal with teacher
gets as far as effective schools are the
sources of community for many years
we've had a preschool in Yonkers and
it's a source of community that brings
together people because we have we teach
scientific procedures for raising
parents I mean their parents raising
children and those are necessary they
it's necessary to cross that
generational gap you know we're talking
about in many cases education across
generations we're talking about
grandmothers grandfathers and children
how do you bring that together for
health for many many reasons there is
the science of teaching and learning
it's not a cognitive science it's a real
science of behavior I'm going to tell
you about it and from
my point of view I take the position at
the proposition that science tells us
what works in a given endeavor it is
clear that there is now both the science
of teaching and learning what works if
it doesn't work get rid of it we don't
need to still talk about Freud twenty
years after there's no evidence that any
of this works bury the dead stuff we got
too many other things to teach I'm gonna
think about a 27-year record of applying
the ever-growing components of the
science and a few model research and
demonstration centers the basic science
consist consists of these parts it
consists of the basic principles of
behavior and these basic principles of
behavior have been growing in been
around since about 1938 one of the most
important ones is found with the
basement of Horace Mann I mean in the
basement of the main hall which is now
called yeah zanko Hall is called the law
was that the basic principles of
learning and the basic principles of
teaching those are all a little bit
different also there are over 200
chapters think of this is over 200 kinds
of medication from the Applied Research
that can be used by people who know when
to use it for whom and under what kinds
of conditions so that already tells you
about the differences in what you have
to learn so I want to talk about the
categories of the application of the
science one is how to ensure that you
have attentive students and effective
performance by students and
professionals Wow if you could do that
in the Board of Education in New York
City get up it would change everything
yes we can and yes we could it would
require a major operation but we already
know how to do them that's a piece of
cake that's not the problem first you
have to have your attention just get it
we know how to do that the next thing is
how to teach children to do what they
could not do before you know that
doesn't mean you give them two weeks of
reading and if they can't do it say well
he made it he didn't you talk kids to
ride a bicycle
that you give me one kid five days on
the bicycle or another kids five does it
mean it would ride the bicycle does it
then you have to teach until the kid
works so and that means teaching means
only when you're able to produce the
outcomes for the student otherwise it's
not teaching so how to design an
instruction that teaches function this
is really important because when we
teach children to do the things that
work under the right kinds of conditions
they'll already know how to do it it
isn't something to store it in the
memory it's stored in what you need to
do at any given time given the
conditions to do it then of course if
you know about these things like a lot
of Medicine knows about a lot of things
to think they like and most schools like
is how do you decide a schooling
organization so that they don't end up
with having to apologize how do you do
it so that you do have the students
performance driving the system this is
about designing contingencies that make
organizations work or not work you can
leave it to non-scientific procedures
and let it evolve that's what we've
tried okay what am I doing wrong here
okay I'm out it again there we go I just
need to move it forward I must have hit
the yeah I got it no I think I got I got
and how do induce new learning
capabilities now this is something we've
learned over the last five years and
it's really exciting stuff you know I
really saw a movie about a coach in the
inner city who stopped his basketball
team from playing in the finals because
they were doing well and so he took them
into the library said okay you guys
study so they studied and then they do
it wouldn't help
at that stage because you have to go
back up and Pete pick up the pieces you
have to have the cable goes and paste
for kids to be able to learn from
certain kinds of contact so we are
learning about that
we're already how to get kids so that
they can learn language incidentally
that was a major step for us let's do it
again
what I'm doing is hitting this keypad I
realized that alright ok I got it out so
that the key to effective application
and this is critical is critical
medicine it's critical in any
organization you're going to make it
work and that's measurement measurement
measurement and what's important is what
you measure not people's attitude about
how they feel about it
not raises up as you know semantic
differential skill how did the teacher
feel about it how the principal feel
about it did the kid learn could they do
it given the conditions in which they
needed to do it direct measurement of
kids learning we measure every response
with all of our kids to all instruction
across all curricular areas and we
generated about 3 million data points a
month
I thought you figured out what doing
doesn't mean I won't continue to do it
so this involves continuous measurement
moments a moment and we measure the
learning the behavior the development of
children students we measure the
teaching behavior of teachers the
supervising behavior of supervisors
which is not sitting in your office and
we measure the teacher mentors I'm a
teacher mentor so in our 27 years in our
schools we measure all responses of all
children to instruction the children's
achievement of educational standards
which is more important than achievement
test the effectiveness and quality of
the teacher
teachers decisions about the selection
of alternative tactics remember I said
those 200 tactics you have to know what
tactic is needed by giving kid at a
given time what about a kid who can't
talk what about a kid talks really well
can't read can't write has these kinds
of conditions what you do with that
particular kid the effect is is the
quality of a supervisor interaction with
the teachers if the kid doesn't learn
it's the problem of the supervisor if
the supervisor we can't get it it's the
problem the university program that
teaches it and you have to organize the
system so that everybody has a
responsibility in that system the
overall performance of the classrooms
and entire school is relative to key
components of instruction and key
learning outcomes for example in our one
of the class I'm going to talk about our
end of our second grade class the kids
get 16,000 room units a week now that's
you don't know what that is but I know
that's really important the response
units changed so if you don't have that
kind of measurement its problem you've
got to wait until the end of the year
what happens with most kids is they they
get to the third grade before everybody
finds out they can't read fact learning
and teaching people sometimes they have
a hard time understanding what learning
is ever tell you what is learning is the
acquisition of new operants or
higher-order operates and that's a
technical term and I'm going to it very
much but it's the learning that's a
function of incidental or designed
environments teaching is the arrangement
of conditions such that learning occurs
as a function of those arrangements that
a children can't learn incidentally a
teacher is a person and a teaching
operation is something that leads the
kid to be able to do it because of that
intervention and that's my definition of
the teaching if all you have to do is
leave the morning on a stomp and run
those who already know how to do it and
have Lord
at home will gather and that's why we
continue to the hands of the perennial
problem teaching occurs where the
learning is a result of teaching awkward
sand hi what are these operas consist of
motivational conditions of the context
in which you learn specific antecedents
that occur before what you see what you
hear what you taste all those things the
actual behaviors you've always had those
behaviors it's still learning the
antecedents and consequences of what you
do and the consequence and the
consequences it worked
it's called reinforcement it doesn't
work it's not gonna keep the behavior
going that's true with reading that's
true with math there are lots of things
you have to do however to get kids past
the difficult part when it's not
automatically reinforcing when you learn
that it is in your repertoire it's not
in your memory it's not stored in an
executive function it's not in your hard
core all those are great metaphor that
it's given the conditions of having to
do it you will do higher-order ones are
the types of operates that when you
learn one many others are available
without the structure remember I talked
to you about how to learn how we know
about how to get kids to the stage they
can learn in ways they could not this is
an example of that world also then what
you know about that you have to have a
system to make sure it works so that
students responses drive the consequence
let me say it again
student responses drive the consequences
for everybody in the system what do you
have to do in order to do that you have
to measure student responsible teachers
are strategic scientists or not
technicians not people are going to just
be creative from mama - mama they have
to do what works under certain kinds of
condition supervisors they have to be
more advanced scientists they can't be
people simply just get a degree show up
and sit in the office they have to be
able to know what to do and a teacher
can't get the kids to learn the teachers
are their students and they are
countable for their students the
administration is driven by been firmly
accountable
conditions now we're talking about our
schools now everybody else is different
university courses in our program based
on what works for the students in the
schools they spend the day in the
schools I graduate students working with
kids that come to class at night the
coursework is will related to what they
see works in the classroom so in our
case they training and I put them here
so the teacher expertise based on a
science there are three tiered levels of
board board certification there are
three levels of supervisor professor
certification there are types of teacher
expertise based on functional
relationships to students learning that
is we know that certain kinds of levels
of expertise kids will learn more
without that level expertise they will
not learn as much so we make sure the
system that those people who are
teaching who don't have that expertise
are supervised with people with that
expertise pair identification is a key
part of our preschool program that's
where I keep saying to the health folks
get in here we get parents who are able
to handle difficult children with autism
behavior problems whatever so that it
don't abuse them right is the place to
teach them about health right and we
also have presuppose that we have
wealthy people working with very poor
people under conditions where they can
both got the same problem it's called a
young continuous and we're the both
together and we are brothers and sisters
publicly funded none of this is grandma
none of the hundreds and thousands hours
of data collection a research is based
on a grant if we're good enough for your
kids your school system will bring us in
to do it and the parents will make the
board do administration doesn't care I'm
going to show you the amazing data do
you think the administration care
they're worried about job programs but
the parents sure do
so some problems are privately run like
we started preschool 27 years ago but
it's publicly funded we have developed a
few little schools mostly of these for
kids with autism in the USA in Ireland
and England and we've been influential
in Spain we have something started Italy
we have a constant evolve of people in
Norway so Abaddonn in Nigeria schools
that create a sense of community that's
the place to go it's not only churches
that cream creates its community I'm all
for churches but the schools can be
cross-cultural cross community right
children are a level or young children
level everybody research base 65 years
of the basing polite science BF Skinner
1938 padlock basic stuff also 26 years
of kaabah systems research search
applied behavior analysis many video
evidence published in over 25
peer-reviewed journals experimental
science of the behavior the individual
to teach each individual control and
experimental groups which I've dug many
studies up are weak for predicting the
behavior of individuals or the learning
of individuals afford to do that you
need experimental science of predicting
the behavior of individuals behavior
analysis has developed that I can tell
you given certain characters super kids
once probably like to work if you look
at that an experiment with a couple
groups can say if this kid belongs to
this population it'll probably work but
13 you said I'm gonna die at 30 percent
of early super people the identification
of verbal developmental stages we
actually identified how kids acquire
certain kinds of verbal behavior not all
kinds of being as a function of the
experience and what kinds of experience
have to preflu that in order for
children profits from that so the goal
is a theft to get education not just a
quality of funds nor equity of presence
of fun
there's not a few fun people it doesn't
work people said we get 30 minutes of
speech therapy but why well because
you're it's a band-aid well what's that
mean does it work
that's what the only thing that America
has ever had to the world as they
develop assistance ever maybe we ought
to treat people based on whether
something works we never quite applied
it as broadly as we shouldn't have
quality is quantifiable yeah quality is
quantifiable and I'm lost and this is
Valley right somebody's kind of my
rescue
so quality is quantified okay so I don't
know what qualitative is listen okay
we're good all right so all children
weld you do the homes poor children
children with disabilities the reason
that we've developed schools all around
the world is because well-educated
parents of children with autism found
out from our research if this stuff
works for all kids and came and asked us
to do that the governors didn't do that
parents and IRA made the government
Ireland do it okay
so one of the first things you need is
adequate funding in many places we don't
have adequate funding it's just going
the wrong place so for our
policies same as regular funding and all
school districts that we work in Shaun
receive free or reduced lunch we're
talking about our kids and other kids
it's not done as well as it should be
done we're not thinking about nutrition
the way we should be most schools aren't
thinking about how do we teach kids to
like things that they don't like that
are good for them but we don't something
about them we have state certified
teachers and they also trained in our
sorry
more certifies the class sizes reason 1
society the class ideally to determine
by the verbal development levels of kids
so we have kids you don't talk that we
get to talk it might be what I want so
I'm going to talk to you about the
outcomes for our what we call accelerate
independent learner model which is a
regular education model that has all
kinds of kids in it I'm going to show
you some data after 2 years these kids
are with us 2 years what I really want
to do is get these kids at 2 years old
but I'm trying to raise some money to do
that today right here are the
standardized test scores and in the
second grade in reading language and
mathematics and these are the teratoma
achievement test scores we began with
this model in the first grade they are
now in our coppice ail 3rd grade 1 of 6
first grade classes in this particular
public school and we are now treating
another teacher to do this - so here's
the composition of the class this is the
weight classes all look
23% of diagnosed with autism spectrum
disorders whatever that is not probably
seeing more devaluing world 23% children
from families in which English is not
spoken in the home that's the most
difficult group to teach in American
education in the world today start to
happen in Europe - 35 % ethnic
minorities 42% low-income and 23% upper
middle class not minority not special
education english-speaking families okay
and there is a teacher I won't go
through this I'm fine so here's the mean
across the class in language reading and
math so the students after two years
perform on average mean at the four
point two nine of the fourth-grade level
at the end of second grade that's across
all these kids that's two and one-third
gray
levels above their actual grade let's
not get non-grade okay they perform the
84th percentile nationally meaning they
performed better than 83 percent of
children in the USA and only 15 percent
of the classes in the USA performed
better the inertia segments language
group now remember this is no difficult
approach to teaching in the country you
go up to Springfield Massachusetts
Barbara's art has a huge study of those
kids falling for many years biggest
problem kid comes in a country young he
doesn't have very much Spanish doesn't
have any English can't talk to mom can't
talk difficult difficult so these kids
performers at the fifth grade level
across language reading and math one of
these little girls my favorite little
girl 87% naturally 87 percent nationally
in second language ethnic minorities
Bieber in level six point two three four
grades above age level and we're talking
about the Board of Education talking
about getting people on it I'm grade
level brave Lori's is from three point
nine to seven point six the Lord's kids
perform a grade I was too great levels
above all they should do 91st percentile
national now nervous now this is 6th
grade so keep in mind that it to get
other four grade levels above it if we
get up the other group you going to
still see it gap but I'm gonna tell you
where I think it is
so here the low-income students which is
42 percent of the class that's problem
bothering me before it's sixth grade
91st almost 92nd percentile National
autism spectrum disorder in the same
class this is real integration folks but
these kids couldn't be in that class had
that have not been prepared to have the
learning capability
to learn from that class and had we not
had the kinds of people trade to work
with him to do that so these are all
minimal upper income students families
in fact they're the reason we're in the
public schools because the family was on
the models how am I going to do it once
you can be regular around and so they
make the Board of Ed do that at some of
these out of this thing they bring in
the money and they support whatever so
the meet performance level of these kids
is about two point nine seven and if we
take out the kid that was not should
have been in there we later found out
didn't have a capabilities and needed
other kinds of things the grade level is
about third grade and the range is from
one point two to four point six sixty
four percentile so at least on or above
grade level upper middle class not
monarchy not special education that's
the Aeons top of your formula and I
think we've got a equal B here
twenty three percent of the class for
students and still with us right mean
performance 8.46 great loads a pop
Braves fifth to almost the eleventh
grade do you realize how fast we have to
keep people going to get the material
these kids that's where all these
kitchen beautiful 97% table management
I'm not going to go through the report
all instruction is based on scientific
procedures which means their catalog
doesn't mean it's based on my
personality somebody else's personality
if people are trained and monitored to
do this and know how to do the
procedures at the right time they're
replicable when teaching is an art and
stuff - somebody's individual or
whatever we're teaching the society can
replicate it so that's the difference
between teaching as a science and
teaching as a crap
I don't offer anybody taking any
approach to education that teaching that
they were
okay you would take a qualitative you
could take whatever you want to do but
this needs to be on the table is
alternative to okay a science of
teaching so I have been as the behaviors
and the person that tempting to be a
science of teaching such a small
minority in this institution for so many
years but it's changed because it works
for the kids and it's got to change so
all the procedures we use are replicable
including how and when to do them and
the measurable quality and using them so
it's a science for teaching and
performance manage the class so that
students love it they'd love to come to
school we don't use cursive procedures
in our preschool kids cry when it's time
to go home and you can guess who those
kids are so a teaching of new operants
are the behaviors the motivational
conceit you gotta want it you got to
have people a situation where they want
to do it and they have to be teach it so
that it's clear to them you have their
attention to get the behavior and the
consequence works and when you do that
until you could step back they have it
it's not in a memory it's not stored in
some mystical place given the conditions
in which they need it they will do it so
teaching them to do that to have those
to do things they could not do before
finally to manage the application of
these scientific procedures this is
needed so desperate measure you know my
my daughter my youngest daughter's a
pediatrician she sees this all the time
biggest problem in medicine is get
people do what they should do to get
those people of a system to be able to
do what they should do without hey it's
your fault see that the effect on the
patients help should drive the whole
system not to eliminate people but to
change the system so this is what we do
at one school so it's a sign for
creative design - so you have to think
based on what we found at about 20 plus
years of
a verbal behavior you need to teach
people to write so that they write the
other way it's going to pay off is that
if somebody reading it can do what they
the writer hasn't do you teach people to
write like that to talk like that they
write really well structure follows
function teach people to talk that way
let me tell you most middle school a lot
of schools in the city kids go around
cursing using bad language and you know
most people think these kids are bad you
know the problem yeah I'll have any
other language
this really is to them just and
they have not been chopped
Hart and Risley impoverished fingers get
two thirds fewer lines the children get
two thirds fewer interactions in
language through well-to-do families
they also miss these Berlin without
level cost nothing ghosts appear so here
they're working two jobs and used to be
a welfare in that study and they have
more kids and we're just not enough
people go around give the interactions
so that kid gets to kindergarten and
they're already you know two-thirds
behind the teacher doesn't have a clue
how to interact with this kid and can't
give them the ketchup things that we
give them right for example our babies
in the lack of the second white would
take it like 100 extra instructional
units and they have a good learning new
words last year's Lisa my favorite
little kid that group who supported at
6:29 great low now and we have all these
pictures and things and she loves
anything that would go through tango on
the refrigerator whatever it is and she
tax him really fast and she asked the
teacher she can take it home and use it
for parents so how in the world and kids
don't know the name of things see it's
not it's not just they're trying to get
they don't know the name of things so
that has to be fixed fixed so we have to
teach function with structure so we now
know how to juice capabilities
that we could not do before this is a
little hard to explain they already have
talked about it's not behavior when you
manage behavior when you get kids to
behave well and do well in your
classroom or your chalk children in your
home already Church where you go that's
something they already know how to do
you just have to know how how they act
can get them to do what they already
know how to do and that's a sign there's
a science about the second thing is you
can have kids doing that and then
they're trying to learn how to read and
they can't do it right so if you can
teach them if you know the right tactic
to read unless unless they do not have
that develop little capabilities to do
that either because of native
disabilities or because of economic
disenfranchisement now the reason we
found this is because we found lots of
kids with disabilities and we've learned
how to get them to get those
capabilities and then we found lovely
how that was a problem with the kids
from the economically disenfranchised
community they didn't have enough
language and then have the experiences
that allow them to build on that and
once we did that we could make progress
so these are what we call the
developmental levels a developmental
level of those beams and behavioral
development web these that is a behavior
because T is so often difficult to
acquire once acquired an individual can
do things they couldn't do before and
they can learn things they could not do
before
for example before a child walks and
just don't come into contact with many
things they're not going to learn it on
us these once they learn how to walk
they come in contact with lots of other
things that they learned
they also become capable of running
skipping other developmental
possibilities become impaired so we've
identified search stages and we can get
children through certain levels of
development which it allows us to teach
them in ways they could not learn before
indirectly and to teach them new
developmental custom so the other thing
is they acquire the foundations of the
observing that accelerate race of
learning for example one of the big
reasons that children often have
difficulty learning to talk is they
don't the the voice is not a conditioned
reinforcer for them it typically happens
in utero and surely after infancy but
that can not happen for various reasons
and one that's missing you can go back
and induce that with certain kinds of
Pavlovian period procedures so in
looking at here's one for example this
is a really a bomber we already know
from years and years of descriptive
research that the more books in a home
write the more likely the children are
to read well do well right everybody
here that while here's the source a few
ten little kids and the first study was
done with Mandarin Chinese children
Stassi it's a matter and if you
condition that you use a procedure
called pairing that conditions the books
so that kids will go to play or and
choose to look at books long before they
can read nothing it's thousands of times
you go in our school the kids go to play
area I got toys they got everything up a
couple buck I don't care the pages this
conditioned reinforcer yep one of the
major parts of learning is to get
conditioned reinforce its problem with
addiction is the lack of conditioning
reinforcement your the more conditioned
reinforcer is you have the offset
addiction better
yeah addiction is there because they're
unconditionally it was very easy sugar
is an unconditional reinforcer right
Harrods and I conditioned reinforcer
books are condition reinforce this music
the level of that compared to what you
have to learn something so guys have
these conditions of observing responses
to even though there's anybody in the
room ever see a kid that somebody walks
that room they don't even know they're
there
okay alright if you get kids to look at
the book so they want to do it then I'll
do it in free chocolate we can do that
reliable have been doing for years they
will learn to read to four times faster
because they're already looking at same
thing goes with voices if voices are
conditionally unfortunate you can teach
kids to discriminate as a listener and
to begin to speak much faster same thing
with me is it if you get a kind of music
is conditioned reinforce it did ten
years of service to another a kid to
learn how to play and discriminate four
times faster so that's the prerequisite
that's a real empirical definition of
readiness alarm you don't have to wait
to the little weeds grow right you can
make the development you see like you
got four years Libra Natalie wrote here
said you know you have to wait kids to
read the first grade turns out and the
stuff she was talking about endings have
infants discriminate fun names don't
wait the weeds come and quick
individualization everything we do is
individualize until we teach kids that
they're bad teacher group at that point
they monitor the wrong behavior on a
second grade they monitor their own
behavior they grab their own behavior
and eventually they're gonna have to be
just have people talking they learn so
this is our system which doesn't show up
here I'm really sorry but
anyway at the top you can't yeah this is
our organizational chart who usually
sits at the top a lot of children who
ever wear it is the oh
tired - okay everybody says I'm a child
centered front to be a child you have to
graphic you have to put it on the board
so there's everyday apparently coming to
help my child met the same well they
didn't be the same all right coughs
ought to know charlie it started paying
attention
okay now how did it that would be sort
of medicine we probably thought of how
they organize it why is that isn't it
better if you get worse and why is that
it's not dumped by the doctors probably
because of the system innovative
curricula Poland's management across all
categories into the next part of our
system our teachers parents and these
are teaching trainers over here so these
parents we have an educational system to
teach them how to teach their kids to
behave well and also learns interesting
time toy train you get time teacher why
does your child go in the corner you see
Ricci well because he doesn't have any
conditioned reinforcer you must stop the
behavior going to change the environment
all the behaviors we need in our tackle
I would have a more bored its the NFC is
a consequence of controlling what we
call education
okay keep at it
multi-tiered system the teacher I lose
our university system do the same thing
it just takes them about 20 years
teacher supervisors are responsible for
the teachers the teacher trainers
responsible for the parent education the
parents come to the school they take
partner training to work with it on
child by working with other Jill
they can do that and then to go back
work for each other then we have this
thomas board here which is together than
three or four universities of marketers
the system and myself and several people
in university go and continuously
monitor through the data example i
haven't dated for molly all the kids and
all the university having all the
schools and then the university is
supposed to be driven by that but you
can't miss a one channel center and less
than ten jury comes in every day this is
what it's like the scale if you have to
go with a will be that scale every day
it'll make a difference and i know they
tell you only one holdings away it
doesn't matter you get on that scale
every day you do that every day of a
certain time you'll take care of your
weight problem every day now what are
your two system we have to you can't go
to member lets you have set up sales
that's gonna drive what do and the thing
that has to drive not standardized
tested yeah that's okay
I'm a mere boomer that's good now we
can't go a week without catching all
right Steve and I have to go I had a lot
of data but there's a book right the
first one is online sample that's about
this verbal capabilities very
complicated you probably wouldn't fit
out find a lot of it but it's it's very
interesting and it's helped as big a
huge difference the first book is about
our system and that system can be used
across medical it can be used in many
ways
Westinghouse which is an organization
used to exist tried to by the nineteen
eighties but I've said we had enough
refrigeration we had too few kids either
what to do thank you very much
I'm sorry
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu